[Music]
welcome to this episode of uxd where
we're going to learn more about lean UX
and why it's important in creating
products that people love
I'm your host Nazmul Idris I have a very
special guest with me today Laura Klein
author of UX for lean startups welcome
to the show hello internets before we
start talking about lean UX we should
perhaps address lean startup first so
Laura what is lean startup so lean
startup is a methodology that was
created by Eric Ries and it's based on
lean manufacturing which actually came
out of Toyota Lean Startup is about
learning as quickly as possible and
reducing the cycle time through what's
called the build measure learn loop the
idea is that instead of just you know
assuming that you know exactly what you
should build you form a hypothesis that
something might work and then you've out
then you find the fastest way to
validate or invalidate that hypothesis
that makes sense the goal of course is
to you know create things that people
want to use and that they will actually
buy and we do that by learning and
validating our ideas in every step of
the way that makes sense so Laura word
on the street is that I can make some
products very quickly and on the cheap
without spending any money on design
using this Lean Startup thing is that
true no I know it's terrible that it
isn't but it's absolutely not true
cuz Lean Startup really it's not about
being cheap and it's not about being
free or cutting corners and just because
you're bootstrapping your startup
doesn't make you lean I mean okay so it
turns out that lean startups can end up
spending less money and time than other
startups but that's because they're
constantly evaluating whether they're
building the right thing and that
minimizes waste just saving money or
going fast does not make you lean that
makes sense so what is lean UX and how
is it different than Lean Startup lean
UX is really just a way to apply those
iterative methods to the user experience
design practice doing lean UX means that
you're always validating with users that
you're designing something that people
are going to use it's about designing
products that are both usable and useful
that makes sense so you're in a book
about this right so what type of an
audience would find this book useful so
right the book is called UX for lean
startups but it's not actually just for
UX designers
and it's not even really just for
startups so I don't know maybe I could
have named it better but the book is
really for anybody who's building a
product because design is everybody's
job it gives you a lot of tips and tools
for learning from your users and turning
that understanding into great products
that people will actually buy that make
sense
design is everyone's responsibility we
should say that a lot on this show so
Laura if I want a lean UX organization
my company how do I go about and make
that happen
well if you're in a big company with a
lot of siloed organizations you know you
excellent silo engineering and another
marketing in another it can be a really
big change but even if you're a startup
with you know one designer and three
people in a room there are still some
fundamental things that you need to get
right the ones that I think are most
important are thinking in terms of
hypotheses and assumptions and learning
to validate those before you commit to
building creating cross-functional teams
that include engineering design research
product management and you know whoever
else needs to be involved in these
product decisions you need an
environment where you can measure and
test all of your design and product
decisions and a team that's open to
understanding the real impact that
they're having on end-users you also
need a really different approach to
design deliverables where you're only
creating artifacts that are necessary
for communication you know you're not
making little pixel perfect mock-ups for
every single change and finally you need
support from the top of your
organization because you're going to
have to change the your whole way of
thinking about products you need product
managers and designers to be held
accountable for the impact that their
decisions have on the end user that
makes sense I mean you no longer get
evaluated on whether a future ships or
not you get evaluated based on whether
the changes you make positively impact
user behavior that's a big change that
needs to happen at the very top of the
organization that is so true so Laura
can you talk more about validating
assumptions and hypotheses that sounds
really important but it also sounds
complicated what does it mean exactly so
it's a really big part of lean UX and
it's a big change in the way we work we
have to stop assuming that we know
exactly what we're building instead
we've need a frame everything as a
hypothesis that is going to be validated
before we commit those coding resources
so can you explain that with an example
I can so here's something that I think a
lot of us can probably identify with I
want you to imagine that you've got a
product your product manager comes in
and says our product needs more social
make it more social let's add comments
isn't everything better with social
everything is better with social but see
what happens is that the product manager
you know comes up it's a brilliant brand
new idea for for comments and then the
designers immediately dive in and they
start thinking okay how do I make the
ideal comments experience and then the
engineers go okay great how do I write
this code so that it's you know really
fast stable comments experience but
instead what we should be asking is how
do we know whether this is even the
right thing to build in the first place
that makes sense see the whole comments
feature has a lot of assumptions packed
into it
for example there's this assumption that
by making the product more social our
key metrics are going to improve do we
really know that do we know that adding
a comments feature is going to improve
our business do we even know that people
are gonna leave comments in other words
do comments fulfill either a user need
or a business need or even better both
we can't just you know assume that those
things are true because the product
manager had an idea instead of assuming
that those are facts we're gonna treat
them as hypotheses and we're gonna test
them as quickly as possible and ideally
we're going to test them without
building the entire comments feature and
then launching it and just seeing how it
does that makes sense
so so these are hypotheses how do we
validate them so this is where we run
into a really common Lean Startup
buzzword MVP yeah we need to build an
MVP and an MVP is a Minimum Viable
Product it's the smallest possible thing
that we can build that will help us to
learn whether or not our hypothesis is
true that makes sense I've heard of
these MVPs so aren't they just really
crappy versions of products they are not
ah so this is a common misconception but
an MVP has never you know a crappy
version of a product because it turns
out that the only thing that we learned
from crappy products is that people
like crappy products that's a well
validated hypothesis we know that people
hate crabby things the word viable is
actually there for a reason it's got to
be something that we can learn from but
that made sense so what is the MVP
version of this comments feature that's
a good question there are actually a few
different versions of the MVP and you
could start with any of them sort of
depending on what you want to validate
first so for example if you wanted to
validate whether anybody would leave a
comment at all you might create what we
call a fake door or a feature stub what
is a fake door so if your want to
validate whether anybody's going to use
something you build the very first
interaction with that feature and then
you record whether anybody interacts
with it so in this case you might put a
box on the page that's a little comment
box and it's got a little button that
says add a comment and you let people
add a comment but instead of adding the
comment to the page immediately you
might just give the answer a nice
thank-you message saying you're
reviewing the comment and then you'd
send the comment in an email to you that
way you'd know whether anybody tried to
leave one it's a lot faster than
building the whole system you know with
flagging and blocking and moderation and
everything and then you know realizing
that nobody has anything to say that
makes sense so so that's a quick way to
validate now what if people actually
start leaving comments like they
actually engage with this feature yeah
so once you validated the people are
that people are interested in starting
this process and leaving comments
the next minimum viable product might be
to see whether adding some of those
products to the page actually makes a
difference in your metrics huh so
remember you've got some comments that
people have emailed to you and so you
can add those to the page by hand and
then do an a/b test to see if the
comments you've added make a difference
for example show the same page with
comments and without and see if more
people buy on the page that has comments
that make sense so what you're saying is
that the idea if an MVP is to learn
weather feature product is likely to
succeed before you actually put in the
resources to completely build it yeah
that's exactly right that's a hundred
percent true and that's really what this
whole thing is about that makes sense
so now after the MVP how do you know
when your hypotheses and assumptions
have been validated that's an excellent
question and it's also a huge question
with a lot of answers to it the
basic idea is that you have to be able
to measure your results in some way and
if you can't tell what effect your
changes are having on real user behavior
you can't actually ever know whether
your design decisions were any good that
makes sense
so can you illustrate that with an
example sure so let's say you end up
shipping that comments feature that
we've been talking about you know in
most places you just ship the feature
and then move on to the next one but
what if for some reason that you don't
necessarily understand when this feature
is out in the wild comments really end
up hurting your product oh yeah I know
so I mean maybe it sounds weird but
maybe people are so busy commenting on
things that they don't buy anything or
you know maybe comments make the page
load really slow and you end up driving
people away there could be any number of
reasons that a feature might fail but
the point is that you don't know it
fails unless you're measuring that makes
sense
so is this where you might use a be
testing a be testing is really the best
way to test the real impact that your
changes have on your product but there
are other ways both qualitative and
quantitative to validate your changes ah
that sounds like something we should
talk about in future episodes I think
you're right cool well thank you so much
for being on the show if you want to
learn more about lean UX before we make
more episodes on it don't forget to read
Laura's book UX for lean startups where
she will teach you all about making
products that people love thanks
everybody go and build something amazing
and thank you Laura again for being here
and thank you for watching good bye